well inflation of course it's the the
measure of just how fast prices are
rising
around the economy very important
because aside from anything else
that's what the bank of england needs to
try and keep uh to around
two percent and the faster the economy
is growing often
that pushes prices higher and that will
cause some consternation at bank of
england
and for the second month running
inflation has risen higher than expected
let me just show you what we're talking
about here this line here shows you
inflation so again
just the rise or the indeed the change
in prices uh over the previous year
you can see it was very low in 2015 kind
of around about zero
uh but then uh inflation has risen
uh relatively sharply and just recently
you can see it
going going down very sharply when it
came to the pandemic
obviously that reflects the fact that
people are spending less in the shops
and then rising uh very quickly over the
last few months
up to above two percent uh last time
around that was in may
but now have a look at what happened
this time around up to 2.5 percent
in june that was higher uh than
economists had expected and puts it
quite comfortably above the bank of
england's 2
target in terms of what's pushing it up
well have a look at this this breaks
down different parts of inflation and
obviously there's a lot there but let me
just kind of show you a few of the
highlights transport costs
that includes petrol prices up quite
sharply restaurants and hotels so people
starting to go out again
spending more perhaps you've noticed
that yourselves that's also gone up
quite a lot as well as have food and
drinks uh as well so you're putting up
you're seeing those prices kind of going
up really across most categories
and as a result of that that's pushing
up prices the big question now
is what the bank of england thinks about
that of course you're seeing high prices
around the world
do they look at it and say well we need
to think about what we're doing with
interest rates or do they say look
for the time being we think this is
going to pass and we can leave interest
rates at that very low level
where they are